you know the media the poor media still
has not gotten over this Katy Hill thing
they just can't every two hours there's
another long think piece by some
publication about how Hill was was only
forced to resign for sexual misconduct
because she's a woman and you know these
people are really try they really think
that will that we've forgotten about the
me2 movement they really think that
we've they want to pretend it never
happened and now we're living in a world
where that never happened
The Washington Post just published an
op-ed titled revenge porn drove Katie
Hill out of Congress would that have
happened to a man would it have happened
to a man I don't know I mean maybe ask
Anthony Weiner does that ring a bell
but even forget about him because he
deserved to have his career destroyed
what about all the men who didn't commit
any crimes and were not members of
Congress committing ethics violations
but still had their careers and
reputations destroyed Aziz Ansari okay
there weren't any pictures published but
there was a graphic description of a
sexual encounter that was entirely
consensual but the woman felt like it
was awkward and she kind of regretted it
later so they put this entire now how is
that not a form of revenge porn find no
pictures but there's a graphic
description of this private thing
consensual published and and that was
reason enough to humiliate him in front
of the entire world the idea that women
face more scrutiny for sexual misconduct
is just so divorced from reality so
disconnected from the real world that
you have to wonder what planet these
people are living on just as another
example during the the height of the me2
movement when we especially were focused
on sexual harassment and sexual misdeeds
in Hollywood and among celebrities and
so on multiple people came forward and
accused Mariah Carey of sexual
harassment in graphic detail now you
probably didn't even hear about that
because when when those accusations come
out everybody was just sort of like that
there whatever and then they moved on
she's a pretty
name so you'd think maybe it would make
some headlines but it didn't because
people just don't care that much about
sexual misconduct when women are the
culprits but what the media is trying to
do now is they're trying to flip it
around and claim that actually no people
care more when it's women which again is
absolutely ludicrous it is the exact
opposite of the case and we all know
that we all know it
okay um several just want to get that
off my chest to begin with several
things to discuss today we're going to
talk about
Ilhan Omar complaining that Walmart's
CEO makes more than Walmart cashiers is
that actually she calls that a moral
outrage but is it really a moral outrage
we're talking about that and the NCAA is
is finally allowing athletes to make
some money on their own name but a
Republican senator is not a fan of that
and he wants to punish the the students
who dare to make any money whatsoever on
their own name we'll talk about that
also Barack Obama has come out as a
far-right audio log big development
there I would say but before we get to
any of that a word from kettle bell
kitchen nutrition is you know on
everybody's minds it's what when and how
much to eat it can be really difficult
to sort through that especially if you
just try to go in if you try to go in
cold to Google and just figure out okay
what am I supposed to be doing exactly
and the information seems to change it's
a mess of conflicting information that
can confuse anyone and derail your
fitness journey there are so many diet
and meal plans out there but chances are
they don't take your specific needs into
account kettle bell kitchen knows that
meal planning isn't a one-size-fits-all
which is why they offer personalized
solutions whether you're you know
slimming down or you're trying to bulk
up or you're just looking for fuel for
the day whatever it is there's a plan
for you all their meals are free of
dairy soy and artificial sweeteners and
they're made from ingredients that are
naturally free of gluten so you can even
filter your your choices by calorie
protein fat carbon source Pacific needs
and that's what makes this so not just
convenient although it is that but it
makes
so effective because every single person
this is one of the problems when you're
trying to figure out a diet plan well
many of the diet plans or whatever
Fitness regimes they're they're kind of
talking about a hypothetical generalized
person but no you need something that is
specific for you and that's what you can
do with kettle bell kitchen feed the
champion in you with kettle bell kitchen
go to kettle bell kitchen dot-com that's
kettle bell kitchen comm and enter code
walls for twenty five dollars off your
first two orders for new customers
that's twenty five dollars off your
first two orders at kettle bell kitchen
comm code Walsh
okay so CNBC recently published a report
claiming that it would take a hundred
years for the average employee to earn
what their CEO makes in a year 100 years
verse a year and this is supposed to
highlight the extreme inequality as they
put it that is out there in the in the
working world obviously though there's a
problem here maybe you've already
noticed it that it assumes that the
low-wage employees we're talking about
will maintain that same wage for a
hundred years okay and I have to say if
you have not gotten a raise in a century
then that's probably a reflection on you
I mean you either you should have gotten
a new job by now or you just suck so
much at your job that after a hundred
years you're still getting paid you know
minimum wage or something so that's that
that should be a sign now on one hand
it's impressive that you're still
working at your age but I have to say
you probably should have climbed a few
steps of that ladder by now
Ilhan omar responded to this report in a
tweet and here it is she says Walmart
CEOs salary last year twenty three
million six hundred eighteen thousand
two hundred thirty three dollars a
Walmart workers median pay last year
twenty one thousand nine hundred and
fifty two dollars so you got 23 million
verse about twenty two thousand and then
Omar continues the issue isn't that
these employees aren't working hard
enough it's that our system doesn't
value workers and it's a moral outrage
moral outrage she says now she should
know something about that considering
she commits a new more
outrage every week but this particular
example she picked is actually very good
very good I mean in demonstrating why
she's wrong and stupid the this in fact
to make her point she could not have
picked a worse example than the CEO of
Walmart the CEO of Walmart Doug McMillon
is is not a trust fund baby he wasn't
born rich he started at Walmart as a
teenager unloading trucks in the back of
the store he worked his way up from
unloading trucks to running the whole
damn company this is this is the
quintessential rags to riches kind of
story in America this is the
quintessential American Dream story or
at least what it used to be before we
all became a bunch of whiney envious
babies who rather than working hard we
sit there and say but he has more than
me this isn't fair
he went from loading trucks to being
assistant manager after he got his
college degree then he became a buyer at
at the corporate headquarters and then
and then he ran Sam's Club and then he
moved over and ran a Walmart
international and then he became back in
2014 he became the CEO of Walmart his
first Walmart job was in 1984 he became
CEO in 2014 that's 30 years it took him
30 years to make it all the way from the
very bottom of Walmart of the Walmart
hierarchy to the very top okay he he
started at Walmart two years before I
was born and he only became CEO five
years ago this is a very long time now
what does this prove well it proves a
few things I think first of all where
Walmart is concerned and this this this
is not equally true of every company it
kind of depends on the company but
especially with Walmart there is upward
mobility you don't have to stay in that
$21,000 range for for you know for your
whole career especially you don't have
to stay there for a hundred years
you can work your way up it is possible
to do that at Walmart if a stock boy
working in the back can become CEO
that's pretty good evidence that it's
possible to be promoted internally
second it would also seem to indicate
that Doug McMillon actually has worked
harder than most other people in the
company
think about what Omar is doing with this
comparison these people in Walmart were
making that that 21 to 22 to 21 $22,000
a year amount the vast majority of them
are probably gonna be people who have
only been in the company for a few
months now the turnover rate in a place
like Walmart I don't know exactly what
it is for Walmer I don't have the
statistics in front of me but it's it's
pretty high in these big-box retailers
for fast food because people come in and
they the people who work there don't
plan on being there for very long this
is just a temporary thing they're doing
whether it's for a few months or a
couple years and that's so that's what
it is gonna be for for most these people
at a place like Walmart the majority of
employees are there temporarily and they
have no intention of staying for the
long haul
Macmillan on the other hand got into his
head the idea that you wanted to be a
buyer for the company and he worked his
way to that goal he actually called
Walmart he went got his college degree
then he called Walmart up got in touch
with an executive and asked how he could
train to gain that position now I asked
you how many of these people making 21
grand at Walmart are even thinking about
what their next move in the company is
how many of them are thinking about they
want to become a buyer or how many are
trying to track down an executive they
could talk to about how can I get
training - how many are doing that I'm
not saying none have but I would submit
to you that the employees at Walmart who
are thinking like that and are doing
things like that trying to track down
the people who are above them and asking
about K what are training courses I can
take what can I do people who are
willing to you know he
McMillon bout went to different stores
and different places willing to move
around willing to do whatever it takes I
would submit that almost everybody at
Walmart with that attitude and that
willingness and who also has the basic
competency and the basic skill sets
required almost everyone in that camp
and who wants Walmart to be a career so
now we've really whittled it down here
that's my point
this is now we're talking about a
relatively small group of people in
Walmart and I would say that almost all
of them in that group are moving up the
chain and are not making are making more
than $21,000 a year but as I said almost
everyone is outside of that and I don't
blame this is this is not I'm not
blaming it if you work at a big-box
retailer or something and you don't want
this to be your career and and you're
doing the bare minimum basically you're
going in taking your paycheck doing the
bare minimum and and and just praying
for the day when you can leave I don't
blame you that's I work these retail
jobs that's exactly how I approached it
because I didn't want this I didn't I
have no desire to you know retail and do
what that's not what I want to do so if
that's not what you want to do either
and you're just there to make the
paycheck and that's all you're
interested in fine I don't blame you I
was the same way I totally get it but
then you can't very well be upset that
you're not making as much as the CEO
okay you can't be upset that you're not
making as much as the guy who is made
this is a career for 30 years obviously
now so find me someone who has been at
Walmart for let's say five years wants
it to be a career has been working hard
and is reliable is basically good at
their job yet still is just a cashier
and hasn't moved up at all in position
or salary in those five years I'm not
saying that it's impossible to find an
example I think it'd be very difficult
to find an example of someone like that
because I think almost everyone in that
category has moved up and is now at
least you know is
assistant manager or something they've
moved on to a different kind of position
by now that it and so this is my point
is this Ilhan omar is absurdly comparing
the salary of someone who's been there
only a few months and doesn't want it to
be a career and wants to leave to the
salary of someone who worked there for
30 years and has been career minded the
whole time that is idiotic that is
flat-out idiotic income inequality
speaking of idiotic is an idiot not just
an idiotic phrase it is a useless phrase
it is a phrase that tells us nothing and
that you can't do anything with of
course in income inequality of course
they're unequal of course incomes are
unequal that's because you get paid
based on the job you're doing the
industry you're in and and all of that
people do different jobs in different
industries they have different skill
sets they have varying degrees of
competency they put in varying amounts
of effort they have been working for
different amounts of time etc etc etc
there are 100 different variables that
affect this so to demand income equality
is to suggest either that none of these
variables matter which would be crazy
and in in that our salary shouldn't be
based on that or that maybe these
variables don't exist I don't know how
else you can go with it but then the
question is okay if income is not going
to be based on all of these variables of
which I only gave a few examples how
long you been doing the job how good you
are at it how much effort you put in it
how reliable you are what industry
you're in all of that if that's not what
your income is based on then what the
hell would it be based on I don't know
how else to have an income that isn't
based on that on on on that stuff it
doesn't make any sense so
as long as there are as everyone in the
working world is in vastly different
sorts of situations you're going to find
vastly different incomes and that makes
sense it would only be a moral outrage
if it were impossible for someone on in
the lower tier to work their way up to
the upper tiers but it's not impossible
and especially in Walmart again we have
to keep going back to this the guy who
runs the joint war started in the back
of a store unloading trucks so that
tells you doesn't mean that everyone can
become CEO obviously there could only be
one like Highlander but it does tell you
that it is possible you don't have to
stay there if you don't want to be in
the back unloading trucks you don't have
to stay there forever all right before
we move on let's check in with our
friends at honey you know you ever buy
something online and then after you've
already bought it you realize that you
could have gotten it for less this is
kind of like it's almost as bad as when
you're in an airport and you're hungry
and you're walking through like Terminal
A and you just settle for some food you
don't really want and then you get to
your terminal terminal B and you find a
much better food option but you've
already eaten that's a tragedy and this
is almost as much of a tragedy
not to mention that once that happens
you know you feel like you could be
overpaying every time you shop which
maybe you are unless you have honey the
free browser extension that saves you
time and money
when shopping online honey scans the
internet for coupon codes and other
discounts then like magic it
automatically applies the one with the
biggest savings to your cart at checkout
it knows about every coupon code sailor
discounted over 20,000 sites like Amazon
Macy's j.crew Domino's Sephora Target
etc etc etc I could tell you that we
needed a new video baby monitor because
we have a new baby in the house and we
save like thirty five bucks with honey
and there's just no downside here
there's there's there's no reason not to
use honey unless you like paying more if
you're some sort of weird
you know if you have some sort of weird
thing where you enjoy you feel like you
you enjoy paying as much as you possibly
can for consumer items then maybe in
that case you won't like honey but
everyone else all the same rational
people who are financially responsible
there's no reason not to get it honey is
the way to go it's free to use and
install on your computer in just two
clicks you get you get honey for free
adjoin honey dot-com / Walsh that's join
honey dot-com / Walsh go there now
you're not gonna regret it okay this is
pretty shocking Barack Obama came out as
a far-right ideologue I don't think
anyone expected that to happen but
speaking yesterday he was talking about
canceled culture and saying that
canceled culture is a bad thing and that
you shouldn't criticize people for small
mistakes and try to destroy them just in
an effort to seem woke yourself well
listen went to what he had to say you
know this is this idea of purity and
you're never compromised and you're
always politically Boake and all that
stuff you should get over that quickly
the world the world is messy there are
ambiguities people who do really good
stuff have flaws like if I tweet or hash
tag about how you didn't do something
right or use the word wrong verb or then
I can sit back and feel pretty good
about myself because man you see how
woke I was I called you out I'm gonna
get on TV watch my show watch grown
--is-- you know that's not that's not
activism that's not bringing about
change wow the guy's an absolute
right-wing extremist this this is this
is anyway this is what qualifies as
right-wing extremism these days
basically any rational statement of any
kind puts you at odds with the far left
if you if you say anything rational on
any subject you by default now are a
conservative and that's not the system
that conservatives have set up this is
how
this have decided that it should be so I
would say welcome to Barack Obama to the
far right we meet Tuesdays and Thursdays
at 8:00 p.m. do bring a dish it's
usually a pot like a potluck type of
thing and in fact what one thing I'll
say is that you know with the canceled
culture thing when more and more
celebrities and prominent people even
people who seem to be on the Left are
coming out against canceled culture it's
it's yeah we we appreciate the fact that
they're saying this but it also is
self-preservation I think more people
are realizing that's why there are a lot
of people who participated in canceled
culture and we're at the forefront of it
Barack Obama being one of them I mean
you want to talk about canceled culture
about how about Barack Obama basically
intentionally stirring up race mobs and
and against you know an anti-police
hysteria over things like you know the
Michael Brown shooting which turned out
to be entirely justified by by the
police officer so but I think you have
people like Barack Obama who are now
coming out against it and you can't give
them too much credit because what
they're realizing is that everybody is
susceptible to this that this is a
parasite that cannon that can infect
anybody and this is a ma this is the mob
has as mobs often do the mob has become
uncontrollable and so you thought that
you could whip it up and send it against
other people and what you're realizing
is that know they're gonna they'll get
bored eventually and turn around and
come after you and as more and more and
more people realize that they say that
oh you know what maybe this isn't such a
good idea and to that I say yes you're
right but I'm sorry I really can't give
you credit for that
you should have realized this a long
time ago
so the NCAA finally decided that it will
allow college athletes to make money off
of their own names and images they're
only doing this because
speaking of self-preservation to
self-preservation there they're
realizing that well they're basically
forced into it states are forcing their
hand and they're trying to avoid a court
battle over which the chairman of the
NCAA Board of Governors was very open
about and he admitted that that's why
they're doing this but they are making
the right call if even if only for
reasons of self-preservation now to be
clear about this this is not athletes
getting paid a salary this is well the
details haven't been haven't been
completely worked out yet but the basic
idea is that an athlete can make money
on his own image and his own name so
maybe for example if people wanted his
jersey signed they wanted a signed
jersey of his he could profit off of
that it is his name after all why
shouldn't he it is his name why should
there ever be a situation where you are
not allowed if somebody wants to pay you
money to put your name on something why
should there ever be a situation where
you are not allowed to do it okay unless
you're in prison or something maybe with
the exception of that outside of prison
doesn't matter who you are it really
doesn't matter who you are what you're
doing if somebody wants to pay you money
to put your name on something you should
be able to take the money of course you
should and it's just if you want to talk
about free market you cannot pretend to
be a free market advocate if you're
saying that there should ever be a
situation outside of prison where a
person shouldn't be allowed shouldn't be
allowed to make money or to accept money
from someone who wants to pay them for
their name if because if that's not
included in free market that is the
essence of the free market I can't think
of a better example of what the free
market looks like then that and if
you're saying no to that then you are
not a free market advocate you don't
believe in the free markets and stop
pretending that you do but there are
people that remain steadfastly opposed
to college athletes making any money at
all in relation to the
what the the sport that they play and
and there are people who feel very
strongly they feel very strongly that
college athletes should be broke it's
it's very important is now it's really
weird to me it's really weird that you
if you feel so strongly that college
athletes should be broke it's very
important to you personally that the
people you're watching on TV aren't
making money you just feel great you you
really hate the idea that making money
that at a minimum to me that makes you
kind of a weirdo that's a very weird
conviction to have one of those weirdos
is Senator burr from North Carolina who
said this is quoting from him on Twitter
he says if college athletes are gonna
make money off their likenesses while in
school their scholarship should be
treated like income I'll be introducing
legislation that subjects scholarships
given to athletes who choose to cash in
to income taxes to reiterate he wants to
impose an expressly punitive tax on the
scholarships not on the money they make
from their names and likenesses if
they're selling jerseys or whatever
that's already of course that's gonna be
taxed if that's all on the up-and-up
then yeah you're gonna you're gonna be
taxed on that I don't think anyone has
an issue with that he wants to tax also
the scholarship as a punishment for them
engaging in the free market so this
isn't him saying that you know I've
thought about it and I really think that
in general scholarship should be taxed
which they already are in some
circumstances to pay I think most of the
time they're not but they're it's all
kind of complicated like everything is
with the IRS these days but what he
wants to do is he wants to treat the
scholarship as income only if the
athlete has committed the sin of
accepting money for his own name and
likeness so this is punitive and and it
is it is treating a scholarship as
income and this is a conservative
Republican quote unquote so this is the
n-c-double-a might let these
make a bit of money on their own names
images there are become millionaires so
if you're so worried about the the
integrity of oh my gosh the integrity of
amateur sports okay well it has no
integrity so maybe open your eyes and
pay attention I don't know where you've
been for the last several decades but
amateur sports doesn't exist it is a
billion-dollar industry and the people
involved in it already make millions the
only difference is we make an exception
for the players and they don't make
anything but oh whether they get the
scholarship I'll get to that in a second
the idea that the scholarship is some
great treat you know some some great on
or they'd be given a scholarship so it
means they shouldn't make any other
money I'll get to that in a second but
the coaches and administrators
executives they make millions already it
is a billion-dollar industry and people
making millions on it so it is not an
amateur sport to call that amateur is
ridiculous
the NCAA also is incredibly absurdly
corrupt which is why they're in broiled
in a new scandal every year so it is
already corrupt it is not amateur it's
worth a billion dollars
people are making millions so if you're
worried about protecting the integrity
of this amateur organization you
obviously have not paid attention for
about 50 years because that went away a
long time ago but even you know if it
really would upset you the idea that you
know if someone you know you've got
coaches making ten million dollars a
year if it would upset you that players
made that amount to I don't know why it
would upset you but don't worry that's
not what would happen here I don't think
anyone's gonna make ten million dollars
selling their Jersey or whatever else
they would sell I don't know what in
it's not specific yet so we don't know
exactly we can't really talk about
numbers but I think it would be safe to
estimate that maybe some of these kids
could make yeah I don't know I mean
thirty forty fifty thousand a year
something like that on maybe I don't
know it's not gonna be a lot but
um so burrs response to that to the fact
that some of these kids might make a
little bit of money is to confiscate it
he wants to come in and just take it
he's saying oh you think you can make
money on your own name no I'm taking it
I'm it's gonna go into my coffers not
yours and amazingly from what I just
what I've seen on Twitter anyway some
people are supporting this people who
consult call themselves conservatives
are saying yeah take that money you take
it politician it's yours not his how
dare he he thinks he can make money on
his own name well if I can't he can't I
really think it is jealousy I think
people are just jealous that you know no
one's gonna pay you for your name cuz no
one cares so you're jealous and you're
the well if I can't have he can and if I
think that is part of it because I've
also heard talking about the scholarship
thing from it you'll hear people say
well you know they're getting a full
ride scholarship just to play a sport I
didn't get a full ride scholarship so
they should be happy with that alright
let's talk about the scholarship for a
minute the reason why and you know I'm
trying to be delicate here but the
reason why you didn't get a full ride
scholarship is because when you were
going to college you weren't good at
anything okay no one was gonna offer you
a scholarship because you really didn't
bring anything to the table again I'm
not you know this is I'm trying to be
delicate I don't mean it as an insult
but if the reason why one of these days
I'll remember to turn my phone down when
I do this but this is a speaking of
amateur the reason why you didn't get a
scholarship is because you you know when
you went to college you just weren't
really good at anything and the colleges
didn't need to offer to you because they
could take or leave you it was really
more of a privilege for you at least
from the college's perspective it you're
the one you have to go and beg them for
admission and then when you do come you
have to pay them because as far as
they're concerned if you don't come who
cares somebody else will now a really
good athlete
who especially one who plays in a
popular sport like football or
basketball it's a totally different
scenario because number one this is
someone who is very very good at
something now you could say all you want
that routes they're good at a skill it
doesn't matter it's you say it doesn't
matter they're good at a skill that is
very profitable that that people are
really interested in and and and you
know there are great athletes I don't
think that's a worthless skill I don't
think that athletes do some worthless
dumb thing I don't think I mean think
about what most of us do for a living
you see you sit in an office all day I
mean you think it's what you think what
you do is more significant than what an
athlete does I don't I don't think so
necessarily now maybe if you're a
surgeon or you know something like that
then yes but they're very good at what
they did what they do and the reason why
the schools offer scholarship is because
the school really wants this person
who's really good at this thing to come
to their school so they the school can
make money off of the student and so of
course they say oh yeah come for free
because if they don't let the student
come for free then some other school
will come in and offer the free ride and
and they'll lose out so it's not out of
the generosity of their hearts that they
offer this scholarship they did it
because they want to profit off of this
person who is really good and has a
profitable marketable skill that you
didn't have when you went to college
they do so that's why they get the free
ride kind of scholarship
it is not charity and they did earn it
because they've been working hard since
they were like 5 years old it's the only
thing they've been focused on they put
in thousands of hours of practice at
whatever sport they play and that's how
that worked out for them now the idea
that you know that should be enough
and it's somehow a scandal if they make
any other money it Tamizh completely
ridiculous I would hope we could agree
at a minimum that the government has no
right to just come in punitive Lee and
take the money
because this is really what it's about
these kids have a marketable skill
people are making money off of them the
question is should they be allowed to
make a little bit of the money as well
there's a lot of money flying around
based on what these kids are doing the
only question is that money's already
out there that's my point with oh it's
amateur it's not the money's there and
it's being spent in its spin it's going
back and forth that it's and there are
many transactions happening the only
question is should the kids get any of
that I say of course they should why
shouldn't they who should get the money
should it be only the coaches and
administrators or should this the
athletes get a little bit of it too or
should the government get it now I would
hope especially if you call yourself a
conservative you would agree that the
government shouldn't get any of it what
what why should Burgett any of it why
does he ever say how about butt out mind
your own business
got nothing to do with you but certainly
there's no reason I mean what if forget
about athletes for a minute what if you
know what if somebody was in school in
med school going to school for medicine
and for some reason someone came up to
them and said I want to pay you 50 bucks
for an autograph should that med school
student be allowed to accept the money
of course no one would deny it so why
should it be different for an athlete
okay let's go to emails Matt well show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Vinay I hope I'm
pronouncing it right Vinay Vinay maybe I
love your show listen you every day you
mentioned that venting is a bad thing my
wife thence after work sometimes
expressing her frustration at work I
listen to her and just say things like
it's supposed to get better or it's
going to get better giving her hope and
a positive look ahead I think venting is
okay as long as it's not directed
towards each other I think we have to be
there for each other when things are not
going that great
yeah well there's nothing wrong with
telling your spouse about your stresses
at work it's good to talk about those
things I think the problem arises when
you're constantly dumping your
negativity on your spouse constantly
complaining about every little stress
you have never choosing to keep any of
your negative emotions to yourself and
and that was my point yesterday I think
obviously within reason we share we are
supposed to share with our spouse but I
think what ends up happening with this
idea that well you should never keep
anything from your schedule your spouse
that becomes an excuse to constantly be
vomiting out all of the the negativity
and all of the complaints and everything
and and I do think that sometimes in a
relationship you got to keep some of
that to yourself because the other thing
to keep in mind is okay you come home
you've been stressed out your spouse
probably also has been stressed out so
as soon as you see them as soon as they
walk in the door you walk in the door
and you just unload and do this every
day what about them
you think they look forward to coming
home and listening to you whine every
single day No so that's what I think we
have to look out for in a marriage
let's go to Brian says Matt I'm an avid
follower of you and Dancing with the
Stars this week Sean Spicer is
officially equal to Sanjaya
you said this in one of the first weeks
of competition I thought it was too
early to say that but there was at least
one other chump that Sean was better
than Lamar Odom last week Sean slipped
by in a decent celebrity went home this
week sean has no business being in the
competition anymore but the Trump nation
is voting him through like Sanjaya of
old Sanjaya of old I like that
he even got booed when he was not even
named in the bottom two based on votes
kind of funny he got booed a day after
Trump on TV the audience boos a lot of
the judges but I've never heard them boo
a contestant for being safe from
elimination I guess the joke must go on
I think the only difference is that I
felt Sanjaya really did think he was
good enough to advance whereas sean is
very aware that he sucks at dancing and
I believe he knows he shouldn't be
dancing with the others anymore thanks
for making my 45-minute commute
entertaining
yeah thanks Brian now you mention it
let's let's take a look at Sean Spicer
latest spectacle on Dancing with the
Stars this one it keeps getting worse
but this one might be the worst one of
all
I was working in the lab late at night
with my eyes beheld at an eerie sight
for my monster from his slab began to
rise and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's what I'm talking about his
dancing is getting worse with each round
how is that possible how is he not at
least improving he's getting whiter with
each round by the end of this thing is
he's gonna look like a drunk pegleg
polar bear up there it's who kind of
already was that but I don't know how I
don't know how it can get worse it keeps
getting worse he's getting worse at
dancing as he learns dancing now I've
said this a dozen times already this is
America Bree we reward greatness in this
country Sean Spicer is not a great
dancer
he's not even satisfactory and he's not
even a great personality where you could
say well he doesn't dance well he's got
this charming personality and so it's TV
and and that's why is that he has no
personality speak of no dancing skill
he's known only for being the White
House spokesman how boring and that's
say like why are people rallying around
the White House the former White House
spokesman is now you're rallying cry why
I couldn't think of a blander more
boring thing to rally around and you
know what if this argument doesn't
convince you then what about his dance
partner partner she's a professional
dancer and she's being tied to this
lumbering oaf for months now this is not
fair this is this has become for slave
labor
this is this is enslavement this is
unconstitutional what's happening to
this woman but here's the really
annoying thing if people were just
voting this guy through because it's
funny and they're ruining the show just
for a good laugh then I could kind of
get it and I would say I think it's
still on American and it's still
probably unconstitutional because of
what because of what it's doing to the
woman but I kind of get it because
listen and and I you know as someone who
enjoys trolling sometimes myself I
understand the joys of trolling but
that's not really what's happening here
I think there are a lot of people who
really believe that they're making some
sort of important stand they're making
some sort of important cultural and
political stand that's the impression
I'm getting at least what I've talked
about this and some of the feedback it
seems maybe it's kind of a mix I think
there are some people who are doing it
for a laugh but then there are a lot of
other people who are say yeah we're
sticking it to the libs and Hollyweird
did that kind of thing the kinds of
people who say things like libs and
Hollyweird and Oh bummer you know those
types of people they're the ones who are
doing this and in all earnestness they
believe that it's some important thing
and Sean Spicer thinks that he's also
that this is a you know he's standing
for Christ this is a pissis i think he
said something like that I forget what
the quote was but he tied this his his
awful dancing to Christ in a way maybe
it is we're all going through a passion
in our own way of a suffering by having
to watch this but that's what annoys me
about it if I could just be convinced
that this is all a joke I'd be less
annoyed but the fact that there's some
earnestness to it makes me annoyed but
but not that it really matters that much
I don't even watch Dancing with the
Stars but I have taken an interest in
this plotline and maybe so you know
maybe in the end maybe that's where
really what's what's going on here the
people Dancing with the Stars they
pretend like they're upset but you know
it's got it's got someone like me
talking about it alright we'll leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]